beh affamata più grande mela fatta
un'amica del mare perché mentre
lasciavamo il bagno con il materassino
sono apparse da non so dove un gruppo di
meduse è invece di farmi salire sul
materassino al turismo un materassino se
n'è andata e mihalache conto caso era in
mezzo ottenerne meduse
questa è una cosa che tu avresti potuto
fare a meno
prendete la ciao ragazzi bentornati a
una nuova puntata di vita buttata il
tema della puntata di oggi è infamate
per il tema di oggi ho pensato di
invitare una ragazza che per me è molto
importante un tempo io avevo un'amica
quell'amica dissi di essere gay e il
giorno dopo andò a spifferarlo lei
ecco perché ho l'onore di presentarvi
claudia genolini fa proprio tu non lo
sai ma per me non sei solamente un amica
cioè tu sei un'attrice della madonna un
regista una collega una compagna di vita
anche una cocente delusione per diversi
è un piacere averti qui ma per favore
cosa vogliamo fare con queste vittime
possiamo fare a 30 anni cosa 32 l'infame
per me è stata mia sorella gemella ha
rivelato a mia madre che perse la
verginità con il mio
un ragazzo dell'epoca terribile che anna
si accanì anche in maniera abbastanza
brutta e nei confronti e sarà la perse
l'aveva fatto sesso paio di mesi dopo
col suo ragazzo
e quando il terminale nemmeno da tutto
assolutamente nulla questa vince il
premio di oggi secondo me questa cancell
farei mai o di oggi questa vince il
premio sono assolutamente sicuro che non
riusciremo a toccare cioè se riuscite a
resistere
il resto vi sembrerà garda solito in
questo caso mi autodenuncio perché anni
fa ancora non davano avuto 13 14 anni la
voce contraffatta
io ho fatto linfa nata a uno dei miei
migliori amici che è che anzi ma le
stampelle per che sarà fatto nella
caviglia
io stavo partendo io non rispetti
l'impegno di italiani a casa mia
nonostante fossimo macchine stessi
partendo migliorare le stampelle
prestito perché non vieni a casa mia
poi è arrivato sotto casa mia io non c'è
non so io sono vincolato mi ha detto che
un altro nella risposta ma chiaramente
lui a casa mia è venuto a piedi quindi
si è fatto che ne so non abitiamo in
panni però si è fatto non voleva il vero
ha stampellata con una scalinata inclusa
per poi tornare indietro
ma cosa canzoni di sei un mostro che
hannibal lecter questo se l'è mangiato
lavoriamo per la categoria e fa male ho
scelto di raccontare di quella qualche
in cui uscita da scuola contenuto di
sale
un ragazzo il robot l'ombelico per
andare a baciare la ragazza è rimasta
sotto la pioggia
a guardarli ormai non sei negli occhi
oppure ancora di quella volta e quindi
vita delle mie compagne stronze preso la
mia valigia e la gettarono fuori dal
balcone vista in piscina
per tutta la serata di quello con le
stampelle allora la più grande in
sommata che ho ricevuto nella vita
risale a un periodo in cui ero molto
indecisa tra un ragazzo con il quale mi
ero lasciata da poco è un mio ex storico
quindi era un pontile molla fra i due
non sapevo bene che fare mi confidavo
con quella che ai tempi era la mia
migliore amica
fatto sta che un giorno di punto in
bianco questa mia amica si è inventata
una scusa idiota per litigare io con una
cretina non capivo cosa mai potesse aver
fatto e decise di chiudere i rapporti
con me bene la sera stessa
andò a letto con uno dei due dopo due
giorni all'altro anche con l'altro
non credo serva aggiungere altro stronza
ben questo serviva una possibilità io la
chiamai la mega l'amica stronza ma pure
loro due non è che sono due santi
innanzitutto fare un complimento che mi
viene dal cuore è nato capacità di
scegliere le persone che ti sei sempre
premi nobel vedere prima migranti che
merda asi ciao volevo raccontarti
dell'ultimo capodanno che ho passato da
sola e in pigiama a casa perché le mie
due migliori amiche hanno deciso di
passarlo con il mio ex moroso e la sua
nuova tipo in quel momento ho pensato
che questo potesse essere un tema giusto
cioè tipo divertente che diventano
cattiva io non voglio parlare di
capodanni ragazzi io quando ha sentito
capodanno è un'onta è una cosa
ragazzi capodanno diventa capo danal
perché lui lo soloni colata 1 i motivi
per cui ho litigato fortemente
furiosamente con un nemico è proprio
legato al capodanno
non è che non sono andato al suo
rapolano e sono andato al capodanno di
un'altra persona e come mai perché era
più divertente capitale dell'altra
persona ne avevo il coraggio di dire che
tenta glielo ho detto ho detto senti
guarda ho insistito tanto per fare il
capodanno a casa tua che toccando aver
dato una mano proprio non mi va di fare
il capodanno da te perché c'è
quest'altro questo paese lo raccontarti
di una mia ex collega eravamo amiche mi
chiese poi di aiutarla a fare un lavoro
dicendomi che mi avrebbe poi pagato
fonetico e o spettato mesi finché alla
mia e nessuna richiesta
mi ha raccontato tra niente aveva
commissionato a un amico del padre
l'invio del bonifico dalla botta ma
quest'uomo era stato praticamente
divertito davanti alla posta da un'auto
ma come mai non è sentito la notizia al
telegiornale
io pure a cercare su google
f.cio a gente che c'era stato un
incidente del genere non c'è più fatta
né sentire né a tenere e ovviamente io
sto ancora aspettando i 200 euro
le rimanenti fa bene perché ecco ma per
queste cose io faccio le brutte cose leo
di ventose sì anch'io mi arrabbio molto
incidente davanti alla voce anche chi
arriva è una bugia creativa di
organizzare a tema io mi ricordo una
ragazza
che stava insieme un nemico e si tratta
è morta pur di lasciarlo e il terzo
giorno resuscitò secondo le scritture
non meramente leggero risuscitò ed è
stato pazzesco finta morta 600 morta
ciao guarda lì informate mio ti salute
veramente tante nella vita ma mai come
quella che mi accade a due anni fa aveva
una miglior amica e convertito sonno il
piatto mangiavano insieme a qualsiasi
cosa stesso cerca infine per bene di tre
anni si sposa denis fa e invita il mio
ex appassionato i mondi mettendola al
tavolo vicino al mio perché senza che
faresti nulla lei continuava uscito con
lui come amico con la sua nuova
fidanzata e io non solo non sapevo nulla
allo scoperto perché giornata del girone
b lato e c'erano so nuova fiamma io mi
sono trovato all'azienda ubicato cosa da
una fiamma del nord e poi al matrimonio
con lui è informata di questa non è
finita ma che amici avete ragazzi ma io
ma tutti questi amici che frequentano
gli ex machi ma perché gli ex vanno
frequentati solamente nel momento in cui
non sono ex avevano trovato ha ragione
ma avevano troppa ragione ok se sei tu
la merda si farà mai capitato per
esempio di frequentare ex di amici tuoi
si creano delle merde senologica questa
ragazza di vuole conoscere in 3d ci vado
vicino poi niente mini si avvicina
c'è poi ci allontana
volevo solo volte elettorato perché
dicono che glielo abbiamo detto l'ultima
più grande non ho capito che sto
diventando anche un campano in guerra
i sottotitoli automatici di yuto cosa
essi non scusami scusami terribile che
gli amici gli hanno detto c'è questa
tipa che ti vuole conoscere anche la di
medicina anni fa non è in realtà voleva
semplicemente vedere il tuo naso ma non
è detto che vivono su che è un naso
grosso mi hanno detto no a tutto è molto
più goloso nel mio potergli dire che chi
di naso diego non yellowstone da a
proposito di infamate praticamente un
vecchio caro amico in discoteca c'è
stato un mio ex
la foto un po spinto ecco lui dopo aver
litigato pesantemente con me quando la
foto a whatsapp a mio padre facendo
finta di aver casualmente sbagliato chat
non rido nemmeno per queste cose sono
molto vari annunci lo è per queste cose
sono agibili non si fa perché se io ho
un segreto che non va a ledere terzi no
no è la mia vita privata decido io se
dirlo ai miei genitori
ero a villa borghese a giocare a palla
con mio padre mai andare al risalto in
vacanza col cane al guinzaglio e vedendo
che il cane voleva correva verso la
palla così giri pari ma sì dai
lasciamolo andare il cane comincia a
correre verso la palla la zanna
supersantos bambino giocavo mai rock
abbiamo detto di colpire il bambino alla
balla un mio ex per lasciare in fa ma se
mi ha detto che stava per morire aveva
un cancro al polmone sinistro io tipo
dormivo con il rosario sotto al cuscino
perché pregavo che qualcuno darà solo
salvasse dopo tondo di tempo in cui mi
ha lasciato perché insomma le stava
diventando troppo grande ho scoperto che
in realtà non era vero niente e lui la
usava come scusa per farmi le corna e la
usava con tutte quelle con cui stava che
occhio quello che dici perché capita ma
quante volte to sperare che è successa
una cosa ti sentivi che sarebbe successo
ed è a casa
no contare finta di avere qualcuno ma
poi quante volte hai avuto paura ex e
basta recap il doj blacks è finita da
anni fa non è amica di stesso ragazzo
che io avevo provato con lei e che
l'aveva baciata quando non era vero
assolutamente lei invece era quella che
c'è è nascosto che lui faceva altro con
tanti ragazzi si scavava tutti
ovviamente per la portata ti brucia un
pochino ancora cucciolotto amore
dolcissimo cosa abbiamo imparato 1
non dite ai vostri amici niente non
ditelo l'affare la frase proprio non
dirlo mai a nessuno se non è quella che
l'allarme mi di dirlo ma nessuno non lo
dice mai non fidanzatevi no non abbiate
amici
morite soli
siamo arrivati alla fine i ragazzi
ringrazio claudia per abbiamo fatto 40
volte più di questo video basta